[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm grace helbig
this is a very special episode of not
too deep i'm so excited
to have michelle aiken formerly michelle
vargas
formerly my college roommate and best
friend with me this episode oh it's so
lovely we take a little trip down memory
lane talk about our college days
we talk about starting youtube back in
2007
you know the days when you got into the
youtube partner program and you thought
that you really made it and we talked
about um the time we got too drunk
uh videographing a wedding a very
expensive wedding
uh in central park in new york and that
we weren't allowed to do that anymore
she also talks about her world of being
a life coach for the last eight years
and how that has changed and grown in
the current climate
also brand new mothers are one of you
mothers out there we talk about her at
home birth and it's
wild and if that doesn't appeal to you
she writes fanfic
harry potter fanfic to be exact so hear
all about that on this lovely episode
of not too deep with michelle aitken
michelle hello hello i have to practice
not calling you michelle vargas which is
all i want to do
you are michelle aiken now so
a preemptive apologies if throughout
this episode i refer to you as michelle
vargas consistently and only
i you know i kind of miss it do you
yeah was it a conscious choice to take
aiken as the last name when you got
married
yeah i was kind of in that place of
wanting to just erase everything and
start over and it seemed like a new
notebook but on a much grander scale and
so that
that was definitely that but i do miss
that when i
um show my id somewhere people don't
speak spanish to me anymore
oh yeah yeah that's true also you and i
love fresh starts so much we do
uh that's a major thing which is why i
think this is going to be such a fun
episode i have a million things to talk
to you about because
i went on my instagram and ask people
for questions
and the amount of questions about things
that i had completely forgotten about
is so fun and so exciting so exciting
i know well first of all for those that
don't know
michelle aiken formerly michelle vargas
is my college
roommate bff slash we moved to new york
together
slash we started youtube together slash
we started youtube youtube didn't exist
i it's honestly it was
it's crazy to think about the history of
it all but first before we get into all
of that
um i'm gonna treat you like a real guest
and not a close
friend this is very exciting the first
thing i ask
a lot of guests that are hybrid
creatives
is what's your deal like how do you
describe who you are what you do to
someone you've never met before
um well i know
a very simple question that i force
people that i've never met before to
answer immediately
honestly i i start with i'm a coach
because it's
it's my profession but it's also just
like imbued through my whole
personality at this point where i'm i'm
in
a service industry i i work with people
on having lives that they love
and so that's really and and me too
so that's a really big part of who i am
and you know i'm also own mom
and i'm a singer i've been singing since
i knew what singing was and now i'm
in an iteration of that where i'm
writing my own music for the first time
and working on an album
it's so i'm so excited for you one of
the things when we became friends
and i knew that you could sing very well
i felt like i had a friend with a
superpower
and any time we were in any karaoke
situation
i'd be like write your name down right
now dude you're such a hype woman
oh i because i the one like true
superpower i wish i had was that i could
sing because it seemed so effortless and
wonderful to people that have that
and so when you could i lived
vicariously through you i'd be like get
up there and sing it's reigning men
again
oh that what's my song i have a new song
i haven't gotten to do this yet but my
new
karaoke song is wrecking ball by miley
cyrus
that's a good one and especially that
when you can actually sing and you get
up and sing wrecking ball
that brings a whole karaoke bar together
because i feel like
there's a lot of people that get up
there with a lot of courage
and a lot of delusions of talent
and don't necessarily deliver the things
that you want them to
in the moment but okay let's go
all the way back to the beginning how
did we
meet well let's see uh there was a boy i
had a crush on
who turned out to be grace's boyfriend
yes
but they were on a break we were on a
break oh god and i didn't even at that
point that was like my first boyfriend
and i didn't even understand what a
break was
i me neither to be honest i i was
introduced to you
because i saw a photo of you that he had
one of your modeling shoots and i was
like
that's your girlfriend how lame
and then i proceeded to try and like not
i i got put into two classes with you
and i saw you on the roster and i was
like oh no no i can't be in a class with
that girl
she kind of hates me i bet she hates me
and so i
dropped out of i actually dropped out of
one of them but then i had to keep the
screenwriting one because
i had to take that well i remember when
i met you and you were interested
in writing and interested you knew
everything about friends
that i'd ever still do i know it's
another superpower you have
and i i was just like oh my god another
girl
that likes the things that i like this
is very exciting in a very small school
where can we go with this what if we
team up i mean i also remember that
during that class
the two of us were usually the ones who
were prepared for class we would raise
our hand at the same
time we would kind of look at each other
over the room like oh we think the same
thing and then one day you came up to me
after class and you were like
do you want to do sketch comedy with me
and i was like
okay yeah cause there's i have
forgotten about the whole world of
college sketch comedy
that we were involved in until people
started asking questions about it on
instagram and i was like oh right
that was we did a lot of we did improv
shows
oh gosh we did improv shows and somehow
we talked
our teachers into letting us do a sketch
comedy television show
for credible so i really
i don't remember having any part in that
conversation like i just remember you
being like so she's going to let us
uh basically take over this entire class
with us creating a tv show and everyone
has to have a role
yes it will see in hindsight i was going
through this because i was like how did
that happen
it was that this teacher for a tv
production class or something
uh had asked about what we were doing
and i mentioned that we wanted to do
this thing and so she changed her whole
syllabus
so our class of people that weren't
involved with our friend group wanting
to make this sketch comedy show
now had to work on this sketch comedy
show for the duration
of the semester and it was so awkward
to because i remember her bringing that
up and not
saying like being so afraid of saying no
or being like is that a good idea
that i was like i guess okay great and
then feeling like everyone in the class
thought that we forced
our teacher to do that and have them
work for us i think people
remember that fondly i'm i'm friends
with people on the internet that were in
that class and also the teacher
oh okay well good as as kelly ties
count out kelly she's awesome we went to
ramapo college which is still
going yes it is and uh
in northern new jersey and yeah we got
into
uh tv sketch comedy and i remember
ramapo television network the network
itself like the close campus
network would run we'd make one episode
a month
or something and then they would run it
on repeat on all the college campus tv
channel 69. that's right that's right
remember you made you made a commercial
uh that was a head-on
spoof and no one remembers i mean some
people remember head-on
wasn't it or was that what you made it
whatever it was it was like applied
directly to the forehead and you just it
was like you doing it over and over
again and
late at night that would be on the tv
when like people are drinking
and yes yes and it seemed great to us at
the time we thought we were visionary
it was it was not it was not bad yeah i
think for
our resources because this was like when
facebook started when we were in college
that's wild to think about yeah we were
petitioning to be on facebook because
other colleges had it
and we didn't wow how do you even
explain that to kids
now i don't know i also made two
documentaries about
what is social media doing to us which
now there's a whole documentary
on netflix about that yeah have you
watched it yet
i haven't because i've heard it's very
intense did you see it
i watched it what are your what's your
take away yeah it is really intense it's
super intense and i feel like some of it
it's like well maybe that's not quite as
bad as you're making it sound
but most of it is yeah yeah i think
uh i'm going through my own personal
kind of
breakup a re-evaluation of my
relationship with social media in all
sorts of
ways and so i think that is going to
really yeah push me in a certain
direction um
okay but after we graduated uh we
had a brief stint in new jersey
house-sitting um
this house situation as a job
uh of a family that had was going on a
trip for a month and then
i got to house it and i was very lonely
and i kind of forced michelle to come
and live in this house i was very happy
to get out of my parents house and come
hang out with you
in a random house that was closer to new
york city it was
it was really fun and that's where we
started vlogging that's where we started
doing
grace and michelle letter n in between
uh just these very silly
nonsensical straight to camera talking
vlogs
and do you remember like what your
feeling was about that at the time that
we were doing it
i just remember it was so much fun
because we didn't really have anyone
watching but we didn't care
and our goal i always tell people this
that we had some rules that we made up
the video can't be longer than two
minutes
and um and we would switch off who edits
it like you added one eye and one
and then we would get done and be like
okay i have a vlog and then we show and
then the other one would just like piss
themselves laughing
yeah and that was how we got started was
we were just trying to make each other
laugh we weren't like
maybe we could get a lot of subscribers
there were no brand deals there was no
term youtuber nobody knew what a
youtuber was it wasn't a vlogger they
would be like how's your v-log
v-log yes exactly we were truly doing it
for fun because at the time
you were pursuing being an actual editor
yes i was
i was i had a job i had an internship in
the city that i was going in for and i
was editing wedding videos
yeah tell me about this because i
someone asked
uh do you have any advice about making
wedding videos
in new york as a side hustle and so
explain to people
what your job was this was like your
entry-level job basically after college
yeah i got in there um the man that
hired me
had a lot of stuff backlogged that he
needed edited that
all of it had an issue like oh we're
missing one of the tapes so you're gonna
have to get creative
and you know make this bride and groom
happy even though we lost footage or you
know there was like
issues and so i started doing that and
then he saw that i
actually had talent quickly and he's
like okay i have to pay you
something he said
why don't you hire a team of interns and
they can help you and then you get paid
for the end result and they can have
their college credit cause i wasn't
college anymore
um and so i started doing that but then
one day his camera guy didn't show for a
shoot and i took over
and he's like just don't tell me how old
you are you know like you know
whatever and i did a great job yeah well
that's the thing you always took on and
i think this is
great advice for even now people
graduating or if they're choosing an
alternate path and they're not going to
college and they're trying to find jobs
is the hustle side of it and the really
fake it till you make it kind of
mentality because
i remember you coming back to our
apartment and saying i'm taking on
interns and i was like
how what does that mean do you know how
to do that
yeah what was that yeah what was that
process like for you
um i mean i i put up ads on craigslist
and i
read resumes and i through my own
bias picked people but like now i'm
reading about unconscious bias i'm like
oh my god i
totally discriminated against like
there's absolutely no way i did it
um mostly like oh this person's from my
hometown
bring him in you know stuff like that
like nothing like in city is just just
these little things
or this person seemed to have made an
extra effort one kid wrote me a poem and
i was like get in here you wrote about
it
they stood out yeah um but yeah then i
brought them in and i did the same thing
he did with me which is they tried to
hand me their reel and they said
i don't need that and they're like why
and i said i want to see what you can i
don't even know if you made any of that
right to me like don't show me you're
real who cares
maybe you stole all of that maybe you
didn't even do it
why don't why don't you take the job and
then show me that you can do it and
this is why college really doesn't all
matter all that much if you want to go
into a marriage field like what can you
do
right um so yeah i brought them on and
then and and i actually found out that i
know stuff and that i can
teach and lead a team and it's funny
considering now i
train coaches in a leadership and coach
training program and i train people on
how to lead teams now
i know that's why i want to get into
that eventually but uh well to answer
this person's question do you have any
thoughts uh
still about making a good wedding video
um i mean what we did was that we were
basically a fly on the wall we weren't
doing that thing where we interview
people and have them say cheesy things
into the camera we were making a
documentary
about the day starting from the time
that the bride gets dressed
for the very which i think is a really
common practice now i think that thing
that kevin and i were doing
was really not done back then but now
it's like
pretty ubiquitous yeah and um but yeah
it was like
think about it as art not um you're not
just recording some footage you're
creating
a piece of art for people i also thought
that you guys did a great job and maybe
this is just because i have
short attention spans that you created a
trailer for the day of the wedding oh
yes
yes the short and the long versions of
the wedding because who wants to watch
your entire wedding video
no i don't even know do brides and
grooms who want to
see that at all they watch it once maybe
twice but we would make a short version
that's all in slow motion
set to music like really quick clips and
it would be like 10 to 12 minutes long
and you get to see pieces of the whole
day i think it's great do you have any
i know that we had a wild wedding that
we videographered
one time that almost got you fired your
hair your hair caught fire and i
stole cocktail stirs and yep yeah do you
ever what's your version of that story
i got to go along like tag along as the
third cameraman
uh on i think two or three different
weddings
and the third or second one whatever the
last one
was it was for good reason that that was
the last time i was there to help out
well so here's your bad influence on me
yeah
kevin was always like hey you know if
kevin is your boss at the time yeah yeah
he's like we are allowed to eat the food
it's in the contract he was very good
about this
yeah and if you want to have a drink
have a drink but
you know let's not like get silly yeah
um
but you were like free blues and you
kept bringing me champagne
i i just i have no i had i had no
ability to say no and i was like
and i also don't know my own tolerance
this is also to be fair to give a little
context the
i remember that the father of the bride
was very generous
with uh all of the things that he had
paid what was probably hundreds of
thousands of dollars
for this was like a wedding at the
central park boathouse like
to the max like everything though the
church
was like this beautiful church on the
upper west side or something
and so everything was the most expensive
i've ever seen
anything and we were probably 22 at the
time
so i had never had a glass of champagne
that didn't cost like didn't come from a
bottle that was more than three dollars
so yeah so i took advantage of the free
samples basically
yeah i uh when i when i drink i don't
drink anymore but when i
when i would drink i would steal it was
always a thing like i would get drunk
and they'd be like ooh
these shot glasses and like put them in
my purse
yes that is true very true so we
we imbibed a little bit at this wedding
we were still doing our jobs
as far as i i knew everything was fine
with the wedding video nothing was wrong
with that
wedding video yeah it just evolved into
a bit of madness because we started to
get a little bit more
tipsy and then kevin our supervisor boss
left
and was like you guys can handle the
rest of this did he i don't remember
that
i vaguely remember at the end him being
like you guys got it we have all the
main things because it's just the party
now and like
you guys can do whatever you want to do
and just like close out for the night
and then i remember you on the dance
floor with a
wet a camera on a stick just like taking
videos of everyone dancing and giving
out our business cards at the time oh my
god our grace and michelle business
cards
yeah we have business cards for our
v-log that you were
giving out to people that's how we were
grassroots promoting ourselves at the
time because there was no other
there's no other way to do it uh and
then
the stealing part of the michelle uh
drunk
came out and suddenly she came over to
me with a bag full of
cocktail stirs yeah they were really
cool
it was so many of them the next day the
poor man was trying to address it with
me and he's like if you need [ __ ]
testers let me know i'll find them for
you i was like
it's not a need thing it's a you know
my demon it was a whole a whole scenario
um yeah my hair caught on fire at one
point
from a votive candle during a speech
during a speech
um and that wasn't a drunk part that was
just
that was just being an idiot um
but that was the last wedding that i
videographed and
i think everyone still had a great time
except the next day yeah you were
brought in to be talked
to trouble i didn't get fired but we did
get banned from doing weddings there
we did yes we did um but i like to think
that we
we aided in them having a great time and
that the video still turned out great
uh but now i wanna i wanna go from we
are making videos we're doing comedy in
new york
where do you start getting interested in
life coaching
um it was actually around the time that
we became youtube partners in 2010
yes because yeah because i started
working with people in the personal
development industry doing
um doing videos for their different
online programs and all this stuff and i
realized
oh i want to be in front of the camera
talking about that and then so i started
posting more sincere personal
developmenty
stuff on our grace and michelle tumbler
yeah i remember
and you made fun of me and i was like oh
good point
um it was all insecurity at the time i
was like
i can't handle sincerity so i can only
make fun of it to push it away from me
well you pushed me into making my own
blog
so you start fart with headphones on my
tumblr
um and then i made the youtube channel
to go along with it where i was
combining comedy and like
advice giving which is not coaching but
it's it's in the realm of personal
development so i was doing that
um and then and then a lot of things
happened at the same time that was also
when my mom
was diagnosed with cancer like i left my
full-time job i got a side gig my mom
got cancer we became youtube partners
and i had
just started this channel yeah and you
were
dating your now husband at the time
right yeah
which is a crazy story that uh michelle
and i also dabbled in some
we worked at the people's improv theater
and we started doing like
live shows in parallel to doing these
youtube
vlogs vlogs and we brought on a director
who was
oh this was totally you you were like i
we're like well we need a director
and and we decided it should be someone
who's really funny but doesn't know us
that well
and you said what about that justin
aiken kid
it's back when we were young enough that
we're still calling people kids yeah
because we were children
just an aiken kid i can go back in my
facebook and find the message that i
said hey dude
we're looking for somebody to direct our
show and like
um yeah we had like a year-long
working together relationship before we
fell in love that's so wild so all this
is happening as you're getting
interested in the more serious side of
life coaching and losing my mom and
like trying to balance how do i make a
living as a freelance
video producer also go see my mom also
do this youtube
stuff because that was when our channel
spiked to like 10 000
subscribers right right right the um
uh so what did you
seek out something specific a specific
program because
also i know at the time we were working
you had kind of brought me in again to
working with
um some like bigger names in that
industry
and i got to see firsthand one how
powerful that industry is how big it is
how legitimate it is
and also uh like
how much like social media hadn't even
touched it at the time yet
yeah hardly putting putting video
with your stuff was like a new thing
there are all these women who are like
you're on my vision board to hire you
because of the people i was working with
um but i was just trying to find
something and i was googling one day
life coach training and i really
couldn't find anything like
substantial that way and i said i think
i said out loud i wish someone would
just tell me
what program to take and then my gmail
notification came up
and i clicked on it and it was a coach
who had been a fan of grace and michelle
and her name her name was allie rodway
she was a fan of grace and michelle she
saw that i had started fart with
headphones on and that i was doing like
personal development comedy and she just
said it just struck me that you would
make an innate coach have you ever
thought about life coaching and i wrote
i was like reply
well ally let me tell you something i
was just googling
life coach training and wishing that
someone would tell me
what to do and she was like the universe
is not an idiot
wow yes got on the phone with her and i
was just like
oh i need this i was crying in 10
minutes and i was not a crier
i never cried yeah i don't think i ever
saw you cry
my mom died and i didn't cry like i
later went to therapy and learned how to
cry
but um i cried a lot now but
i'm okay now i i i got on the phone with
her and
she asked me just like a few really
seemingly basic questions but it just
was stuff i was not thinking about for
myself
and then she told me about
accomplishment coaching which was the
life coach training program that she
went through and she asked me
if i wanted to take their workshop and
check it out and i mean
uh i went and i got to like be a fly on
the wall for part of the training and
then i got to do the workshop but within
five minutes of arriving there and i was
just going to kind of like appease her
yeah um but i have five minutes in
listening to the ceo talk about um what
they were doing there
i was like oh sign me up i gotta do this
because it was a group of people sitting
around a table telling the truth to each
other
and i had just never in my life
been in front of that level of
transparency it was
uncomfortable and very exciting yeah
because at that point i imagine like
both of us are being surrounded by
comedians all the time
who comment on truth but from a distance
that's safe enough that they don't have
to like reveal their own necessarily
right right it was water in the desert
yeah it must have been like oh there's
no uh
sarcasm about anything that anyone's
saying what is this this is refreshing
right and so i really wanted to be in
that so i got to do the workshop and be
one of the people who was being
worked with on stuff and at the end of
it they go around they just check like
is anyone here interested in actually
signing up
and when they got to me i just went yeah
and they're like
uh do you mean like right now because
it's kind of rare for someone to just
immediately
be i was like yeah right now uh with
eighteen thousand dollars let's do it
i know i don't have that money i'm gonna
figure it out
yeah yeah yeah i mean this is this is i
to be fair this is your mo at this point
is agreeing to things that you don't
necessarily
know how to do and then figure it out as
you go good point
yeah yeah i have had a quite a muscle in
that so i put myself into
a bit of a vice because i then i now i
have to
because i put money i put money down
it's a non-refundable deposit and then i
was like
okay i gotta figure it out so i did so
you figured it out
uh okay i wanna we're gonna take a quick
break i wanna get more
into the world of life coaching and how
that has served you
uh and also the fact the mother side of
everything
yeah so we'll be right back with more
not too deep
[Music]
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to
hosted by me grace helbig just wanted to
say a couple of things one
thank you so much for listening and two
if you are enjoying yourself to such a
degree that you'd love to leave
us a review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be uh and that was my
couple of things
now back to me me
okay so what year is this that you're
starting in this life coaching world
2011 i signed up but it started in
february 2012.
okay so you've been doing this for about
eight years now
yeah which is wild because i and i'm so
curious to hear
you know in the evolutions of you being
a part of it for so long because
the natural thing that people do is [ __ ]
on it immediately
the whole industry and i talked to
michael buckley a little bit about this
too
what what do you say to people
that still think it's [ __ ]
i don't say much yeah because
people who want to think it's [ __ ]
like they will
i'm not here to convince anybody of
anything
um because it works because you believe
in it
it doesn't inherently work it's not like
surgery it's not like
oh you don't think it works i'm going to
force you to work with this coach and
now your life's going
no it works because you choose for it to
be a methodology
that works for you and it's not the only
one there's tons of ways that you can
change your life and do things that
actually work for you so
if people want to be cynical [ __ ]
that's fine
i'm not interested no ty they're not
going to sign up yeah i feel like
it's like you can play piano if you
take the time to learn how to do it but
so people people are like oh piano
doesn't work
right like it does if you learn it that
doesn't
make sense um no there's a lot of hacks
out there playing piano
that's true that doesn't mean that there
aren't great pianists
and composers though right right right
no
okay so you had one hacky person and
that's it
okay got it yeah have you seen
that world change at all in the last few
years have you seen it grow have you
seen it oh it's growing
yeah it feels like it feels like in this
world because i remember you and i know
like when
youtube first started we were very
much presentational about only the
things that we wanted to show and our
private lives were our private lives
and we weren't so much about the
honest transparency of like mental
health emotional health all of that kind
of stuff
and i feel like zoella was one of the
first people that ever sat down and said
that she has anxiety and then everyone
was like oh my god
this beautiful little pixie child like
if she can say it like i can acknowledge
it to myself so now it's very
like a foundation of a lot of people
trying to exist on social media is this
transparency about mental health
has that affected that whole industry i
imagine it's made it grow
definitely it definitely has i mean not
only are there more coaches there's more
coach training programs now that are
accredited
you can have a coach training program
and then you could actually like get it
accredited through the international
coached federation and back when i
started i think accomplishment coaching
was one of a hundred
or a few fewer than a hundred i don't
know how many there are now
but it's multiple hundreds of accredited
training
programs of different levels and um
accomplishment coaching still
probably one of the longest most
rigorous most expensive like
all-encompassing
one out there it's hogwarts yeah
yeah it's basically hogwarts um it
really is uh because there's
after you graduate if you want to stay
on and become a program leader there's
an advanced leadership training and
um which is what i did yeah before we
even called it that and
now i'm a senior program leader and i'm
the youngest senior program leader
in the history of the company wow
congratulations
thank you doing it
uh here's a question for people that are
interested in finding
a coach or interested in like just
seeing what that world is or they feel
lost or confused or any of that
what what how how should they approach
that
um well they can talk to me okay i'm
good at helping people figure out
next steps like i i love those phone
calls of just like
i feel like a lot of people don't
necessarily know if coaching is right
for them
and i i get into a lot of conversations
with people just to sort of like poke
around and find out
what are you actually up to and where
are you at to help them determine
what's next and it's not my answer isn't
always hire a coach sometimes it's hey
it sounds like
therapy might be a thing and you know
i'm not i don't diagnose
or anything but a pretty good ear but i
would say just like if you're looking
for
coaches that uh looking for someone
who's credentialed through the
international coach federation is a good
place to start
okay that's good to know because i feel
like that's something people wouldn't
know otherwise
right right so there's an pcc mcc
associate certified coach professional
and master
um and really like that there's so
that's the level of quality control in
the industry
okay right now it's a young industry
it's being started in the 80s
with corporate coaching right so right
and we're always like working to up the
level of quality control and like the
ethics and everything around it
um i'm very involved in all of that yeah
and there's a lot of people that just
say i'm a coach and they actually mean
i'm a
consultant they're going to give you
advice and
tell you what to do and coaching is not
that
really i don't it's it yeah it seems
it's almost like and correct me if i'm
wrong it seems like
you approach people like an escape room
like
they you want to figure out how to like
unlock the puzzles and all the pieces
and all the things yeah to get them out
of the room that they're in in some way
yeah yeah yeah but you're showing them
how to do it for themselves you're not
doing it for them
right i'm more like standing next to
them talking to them about it and asking
questions about what they see
that they're not asking themselves and
people i feel like people don't realize
the power of a really
simple question yeah that you're not
asking yourself
because you're not curious about
yourself you're more like looking for
the right answer
which is very different than
wonder and curiosity and exploration
about you yeah yeah because sometimes
like the
the answer you come to isn't going to be
right or pretty or correct
but it's gonna be the thing that moves
you forward
right right the someone asked on
instagram
how do you coach people through such
upheaval ie 2020
can't we all just hide but
i feel like you probably this year
especially
must be kind of bonkers in the coaching
industry
not only for the people you're coaching
but for coaches themselves
yeah i think um a lot of us had we had a
rough time
right at the start of all this because
we're all going through such so much
and we have so many support structures
and things that we employ on a regular
basis and even that stuff wasn't doing
it
i can speak for myself like i um i made
a joke i made a tick tock that it was
like
a clip of ross from friends saying he's
fine
and i put me at the beginning of
coaching calls when clients ask me how
i'm doing
i'm fine that's how i felt
and they were like yeah me too it was
sort of like what's kind of cool about
it is we were
all sort of thrown into this like pot of
soup yeah and we're all like
and so it was just a level playing field
yeah
but what i noticed is because of all the
work that they do it was sort of like
everyone was just asked to lift really
heavy weights but i've been in the gym
yeah you know so i'm sort of like well
it's heavy i got
and i have some people helping and it's
heavy and i'm sweating but i'm not
underneath it i haven't passed out i'm
not totally checking out of my life i'm
i'm working with i'm being with it i
have a lot more be with
so to speak like i have a bigger
bandwidth for what's going on
than the average person because i'm
constantly putting myself into scenarios
that cause that bandwidth to expand
yeah that makes sense especially yeah
because you're you're much more prepared
you've been like doomsday prepping
emotionally
and the rest of us haven't basically and
that's what my clients said too
some of my clients were just i didn't
lose any clients
amazing right i mean i was
nervous but then i'm like no the work
works don't forget the work works and
like one of my clients was just like
michelle if i didn't
have this i don't
i don't think like anything that's
happening right now would be happening
i i don't think i would be able to do
life and i'm like
yeah basically like it prepared it
definitely doomsday prep is a good
analogy part it well i think like right
now there's so many people
we're all kind of experiencing a trauma
on like a big global and cultural level
so i
i think it's that's why i'm excited that
you're on this episode to present this
like opportunity to people that there
are
different ways in which you can like
work with people to figure everything
out for yourself and that like not all
hope is lost
and that uh the industry especially the
legitimate one that you're
in is available to people um
to go to move on a little bit to
something equally as intense and
important um let's get into your harry
potter fanfic world
okay because one of my favorite things
to value is that you are multifaceted
that sometimes you could associate or
assume that like a
a coach or a life coach is just like
woo-woo spiritual whatever
yoga blah blah blah all of that but you
have many layers to you and one of them
is this um colorful world of fan fiction
in which you are an author and
participant in uh
let's talk about that for people that
don't know
what that world is can you explain it
fan fiction
very simply it's like if you if you
really like a tv show or a book
series you can write your own story from
it like
like writing an episode of a of a tv
show you really like
i'm gonna write my own i'm gonna change
it
um in some fashion so the harry potter
uh fanfic world is quite large and um
usu though the area i hang out in is the
uh is the area of draco malfoy
who is a villain had a redemption of
some sort and
became kind of a different person and
him and hermione granger
get together right
right this is germany
yes oh you said it right oh hooray
how do people say it wrong germany oh
drama mean
germany how did you get into this world
specifically
well i think i actually think that in if
i think back
buffy when i watched buffy the vampire
player and her and spike
became a thing that really like that
really intrigued me when i was a kid
and then true blood same thing with eric
the vampire also
blonde um odd
villain and and like the hero getting
together
has always been just something that
interests me
um and so when i went looking at fan
fiction and i saw oh draco and hermione
that's interesting let me read one of
those and i happen to pick
you know i went in and i sorted by
comments
and kudos kudos or an archive of our own
kudos or the way that you know like
people liked it
and i found this one by an author who i
am now very good
friends with her handle is love's bitka
8 which i think is a
buffy reference of some sort actually
but she writes fun
um she writes reylo which is rey
and kylo ren ah and she also writes
germaine and and her her stuff is so
good oh you would love her
um her stuff is so ridiculously good
that you're like
why am i not paying for this how is this
on a website and
she's a she's a writer yeah she's a real
writer in the world who has awards and
like she's amazing
so um so i started reading her stuff and
it was so good that it made me angry
yeah that's that's how we used to say
that we like something when we got real
jealous of it
youtubers were like just like making
fists and being like that's
i really appreciate and respect them but
i'm really mad at them for making
something so
good yeah yeah yeah so so i really
remember
reading one of her things and then just
putting it down and going okay i'm just
going to start writing and see what
happens and i wrote this
160 000 word story that just came
pouring out of me like it was like a
disease i couldn't i mean people were
you were worried everyone was a little
worried about me because i couldn't stop
writing for like a month i remember you
telling me that you had started writing
fanfic and then you just be like and
here's the word count of this and here's
the workout of this and i'm like i
i as someone that's written a book i
can't wrap my brain around the amount of
content that you're producing
as a side little hobby to your real life
well to be clear i was sort of escaping
my regular life and going and doing that
but what i'm doing now is actually
healthy good um i created a schedule
it's on my wall
for anyone watching love it when i write
and
every friday i write another chapter and
i um
actually this imac that i'm on right now
was a reward
slash consequence for having hit all my
milestones in august
including songwriting so i write a song
every monday and i read a chapter of fan
fiction every friday
love it love it you guys monday
fanfiction friday
i mean we're still going back we all
rely on systems right
so the system was i ordered the computer
it was here
and if i didn't hit all my milestones i
had to wait a month to open it
ah so you better believe i hit my
freaking milestone yeah
yeah that's a big way to get yourself to
do it my next one is hair
i made a hair appointment for october
and i pre-tipped my stylus so i i then
mowed her 100 bucks and i was like
so if i don't hit my milestones you keep
this hundred dollars and i'll have to
book again and i'll have to get re-tip
you
later wow that's crystal is uh no one
gets hurt in your production process
exactly that's great uh well in tandem
with the harry potter stuff
someone asks why a death eater tattoo oh
um it's kind of part of a a character
like so i had to create an alter ego in
order to write
yeah and and her name is lillian silver
love it and
so i created a whole backstory for her
where she's from
a death eater family and was like you
know marked and everything and
um and later transforms i haven't
written this yet like this is like
i'm probably not going to write this for
a really long time um
but i couldn't like get myself to write
without
being behind a pseudonym and i didn't
publicly talk about it to anyone
i didn't talk to you yeah i didn't
really talk to anyone about it
um and i was sort of getting in touch
with like my inner
dark side and my inner slytherin yeah so
it's actually
a i'm a hufflepuff so this is a badger
skull and then the dark mark so it's
usually a human skull but a badge or is
the hufflepuff
symbol ah so it's kind of like a
it was like a oh i i actually have i'm
not just like
kind and sweet and loyal like i have a
dark side to me and
i write smut i mean i look i'm learning
about depth psychology right now we all
have our shadow side and it sounds like
you got in touch with yours and that's
fantastic also exactly i think that's
really helpful for people that are
interested
in that world of fanfic but they're a
little insecure
or nervous about putting themselves in
it to create like
a character in which you write through
can sometimes be very
like liberating it was so it was so
liberating
and then i got over it and then i was
like okay i can tell everybody now but
i'm still lily and silver like it's
still my
you know yeah yeah my pen name it's a
fun character
um someone asked any new harry draco
fanfic we can thirst over
oh i love dreary dreary
okay that's another area of fan fiction
draco harry
the dreary is probably the most popular
second only to jeremiah
yeah but there's there's some good good
authors like there's some
really are they asking me for
recommendations is that what they're
asking for or are they
just any new that they can thirst over
um
and with that someone else uh asked for
like your least favorite fanfic
least favorite that you've ever written
if there is one oh that i've written
i mean it would probably be like the
first smut i wrote
yeah because it was so young and naive
it was it's called you're welcome and um
i mean i was shaking while writing it
and it's it's probably fine i just like
i can't even bring myself to go back and
look at it because it was the first
thing i wrote
yeah being like crazy oh yeah you wrote
smut
and it's so funny it feels scandalous to
read smut that your friend
writes when she sends it to you to be
like so you're just right oh wow they're
really doing some stuff to each other
straight up straight up porn they're
always of age
right everything's consensual everything
i don't write a 14 year old
smut i write like i write stories where
it's like
oh they they it's 10 years later and
they're divorced and they're working
together at the ministry for some reason
or you know
like just right into the future so it's
the one people here are harry potter
and smut they're like oh gross they're
kids and it's like no you write
you write all the future you're right
something outside of what we know
in canon right right right right well
someone's also asking your favorite
harry potter story be it book or fanfic
oh that's hard that might be a
i mean my first favorite was prisoner of
azkaban which i feel like a lot of
people say because it's a really good
book but the one that i tend to re-read
over and over is half blood prince
number six
it's really something about the book
like feels like a warm blanket
maybe it's because four and five are so
tumultuous and annoying even though
they're really good
yeah but i love rereading the sixth one
but i haven't read
i haven't reread the books since i
started reading fan fiction and
i was on a tear of just constantly
rereading them because i started that
when my mom got sick and i like didn't
want to let go of it
yeah that makes sense also a lot of my
harry potter obsession has nothing to do
with harry potter it has to do with like
that was my coping mechanism
when my mom was dying so for sure it's
like a part of me in that way
you're connected to it in an emotional
way have you explored someone to know
the draco malfoy genre of tick tock
um yeah that's kind of a new thing draco
talk okay it's happening right now
um and uh i
have something planned um
i have a draco mouthful cardboard cut
out in this closet so like there's a lot
of stuff i
i could do yeah um there's opportunities
for content
there yeah and i have a hermione outfit
that i just got recently
so see like i said a life coach with all
sorts of layers going on well i don't
know if i told you but my plan
is that i'm currently writing this
ridiculous what we call a crack fick
because like basically i was on crack
writing it um
it's really it's ridiculous like it's a
um
the whole story the v it's just a
vehicle for smut and humor i love it i
want it i wanted to write something
funny
um so i started writing it and inside of
it i talk to the audience i break the
fourth wall constantly and just talk to
them
about what's going on i'm like oh [ __ ]
people like it's just
it's a ridiculous story yeah and in it
hermione listens to a lot of mariah
carey like and and gets really emo
and so i'm planning a uh a cover of a
mariah carey song and a music video with
me as hermione
that i'm gonna put only people who read
the story
are gonna get it okay like i'm not just
gonna like go post it everywhere but if
you actually read the story you'll know
how to get to it
oh that's fun a little treasure hunt
yeah that's really cute
okay we have to take one last break when
we get back i have uh you guys have a
bunch more questions and i want to talk
about the fact that you have um
you have a little a bun so we'll be
right back with more not too deep
[Music]
okay michelle aiken formerly vargas
before we get into the last bit of the
podcast i'm going to ask you the two
questions
i ask every single guest that is on the
podcast and the first
is who alive or dead would you most like
to throw cold spaghetti at
old spaghetti um
my teacher my algebra teacher
okay his name i can't remember who
favored all of the boys in class and it
was the first year that i thought oh
maybe i can't do math
and after that it went downhill i was
really good at math
and then that year it's probably seventh
grade it was just like [ __ ] after that
so that guy what the [ __ ] his name was
what a dork uh okay the other question
i ask every single guest is to tell us
your worst pants [ __ ] story
or close call but you can you can only
use three words or small phrases
so mine as always is i know it
college jogging front lawn however
even though we were college roommates
this never happened on campus
so of you were not privy to the the
experiment or the experiment it was kind
of an experiment
uh but i'm curious what is yours have
you encountered people who have never
[ __ ] their pants
yeah and it's um you know i respect
everyone
but it does feel a little uh
suspect i'm like really you've never had
a close call
i mean you don't have there are people
that not [ __ ] their pants i believe that
because some people are responsible
healthy humans
uh but not even a close call
um
kindergarten okay
playground monkey bars
okay yeah that sounds um
yes i won't ask anybody that checks out
i can i can
that seems like a a situation in which
uh a crisis would
emerge uh i mean you're grasping there's
there's clenching yeah you don't even
know how your body works at that point
uh okay let's talk about the other big
area of your life
motherhood yes now
the craziest thing to me about you being
a mother one is all of it
but two is uh your birthing story is
absolutely insane can you
talk about that a little bit yeah so i
don't know why but my husband and i both
wanted to have a home birth
a home birth yeah because i i think this
is interesting just because it's
it's very cool what you guys did and i
don't know but i
assume that maybe people that are
pregnant or want to
be uh would be curious to hear your
experience
yeah i mean i i did a lot of research on
this with justin and
there's a lot of birthing situations
where you you absolutely do need to be
in a hospital
and most of them you don't but i think
something people don't know about home
birth is that you do a lot more doctor's
appointments or midwife appointments
whatever
you're using um and you there's a lot
more
prep and making sure everything is going
to be okay
right and that you have a you have a
private ambulance service ready to take
you to a hospital which has to be a
certain
amount of miles away like there's
there's so many precautions taken it's
not like you're just like yeah whatever
i'll just go over there on my baby like
people hear home birthday like
how are you responsible it's like no no
it's actually you actually have to do a
lot more
self-advocating you have to you have to
know a lot more
um but yeah i wanted to do the no
pain thing and i had heard about
hypnobirthing so i took a
hypnobirthing class with this french
teacher in brooklyn she was amazing
and it's essentially meditation you
learn how to
meditate and do kind of manipulate your
body into
feeling things so that um and i and i
happen to have done a lot of meditation
prior to this so i was really good at it
right away like i did i
i was natural it was a natural it made
sense to you
yeah yeah completely like there are
people in my classroom like it's not
working
yeah and for me she was like have you
done this before
so i i i take to it really well um yeah
and the idea is you you hypnotize
yourself
out of feeling pain and into feeling
pleasure wow
so a very simple process yeah i mean
what's kind of funny grace is that so we
did it at my house there was a
pool i ended up giving birth on the bed
because she was checking me out and
i was like i don't want to get back in
the pool
but i was pretty serene through most of
it it was like
candles low lights uh meditation playing
the whole time a guided meditation with
this woman from new zealand
beautiful accent um and very few people
but the people who were there the
midwife the birthing assistant mcdoula
my aunts
justin's aunt my friend jocelyn was
watching the dogs um
that was it that's how many people were
there yeah of course my husband
but they were for me at the beginning of
it
it felt like a performance i was like
okay
i wanna do this so good i wanna
show everybody that you can you can have
a no pain
process and so i was performing at the
beginning
you know i was pretending to be fine and
what ended up happening
is i actually became fine because
it's all mental it's a mental game it's
like what do you tell yourself when you
start to feel the pain do you start to
panic and hyperventilate or do you
like just go
and just smile i was smiling the entire
time
crazy that's worse i was forcing a smile
like most of the time because if you do
that it sends a message to your brain
yeah we're okay and eventually the
endorphins start flowing and
again this is another fake it till you
make it situation
yes crazy that's a good theme running
through
yeah i ended up having um i ended up
having a an orgasmic
birth which i didn't even know was a
thing i didn't know that was a thing
either
you're welcome
how are you doing this you're so strong
and i'm over there like it feels really
good how
common is that because i feel like if
women knew that was a possibility
maybe they'd be like way more open to
like the birthing process maybe but most
people are just like no painkillers no
way
like i'm just going to throw painkillers
at it and it's like if you don't
your body comes in and helps you with
natural painkillers and so
it's not like you just suffer through it
you're just getting this like crazy high
endorphin
if you think about runner's high it's
like that times a million wow
that's good why can i ask why
you and justin wanted the at-home birth
i had been moving away from prescribed
medicine um
food with toxins like i had been in that
for a while just
intuitively like i think we moved to
brooklyn and i remember looking at my
birth control and just going
i don't want to take this anymore i
don't even know why
and maybe it was the buddhist classes we
were going to and and
starting to look at life through that
lens the meditation and stuff
um but some it was just intuitive it
wasn't like i'm on my moral high horse
and i don't think we should do these
things it was just
how i felt and i couldn't it was so
strong that i couldn't ignore it
yeah yeah no that makes sense i mean
when you told me that's how you gave
birth
i was shocked because i didn't
realize that was an option uh
you and an option that people choose and
want to do
and that you had a great experience
doing it
yeah um but that was now four years ago
amelia's four
he's four it's just crazy someone asked
from
instagram how has motherhood changed
your view of the world
do you worry how different it will be
from how you grew up
um it completely changes your view of
the world first of all
yeah you go from being someone who can
be a little carefree to being someone
who
pretty much is worried all the time yeah
that's i mean
that's what terrifies me about it yeah
like like the kid comes and you're like
wow
okay so now this is forever oh god
i feel like this i mean like i i'm not
i'm not in it all the time i definitely
i had bad postpartum anxiety and
paranoia
like yeah like i couldn't sleep at night
i would be like there's a vast murderer
coming in our house
wow it was bad yeah
but after that and after getting like
back into the swing of life
i'm a lot more uh able to have
boundaries and like
be here and be doing my work and she's
with her granny who is basically our au
pair
that's great you know like we support
her whole life she supports our whole
life we're just
a symbiotic relationship here and so
she's with her granny
or she's with us or she's with her
cousins or you know there's so many
options and and like managing the guilt
was really hard at first and eventually
just
became okay i'm not i don't i don't
actually experience it anymore
yeah the worry and the guilt i have a
lot more trust
and um an inability to like okay let me
just
let me do me because all i wanted as a
kid was for my mom to just love her life
yeah thing about us and what we're doing
yeah i wanted that so badly for her and
i really truly believe that
the cancer and and everything was the
result of just
hating so much for yeah not being
not not hating everything like we had we
had a good life
it was fun i had a fun childhood you
know things there were
plenty of good things but i feel like
ultimately my mom wanted to be doing
something different with life yeah her
job
and and it wasn't happening and there
was a lot that just wasn't happening for
her
and she had to go you know yeah
yeah but that i mean it's amazing to be
able to think that through
from your childhood self and recognize
that
and be able to be present now with
amelia
and know that you want to change that
for her
yeah it's it's it's very challenging
i'm sure it's way easier said than done
yeah i mean like i have my moments where
i'm like am i completely neglecting her
should i
yeah that's my biggest fear is i'm going
to be
so in my head about doing every single
thing wrong constantly that i will
be in my head about everything i mean i
feel like we just
there's nothing that you can do you're
going to do
something that impacts the kid
negatively yeah
but all i can do is ensure that i'm
putting in on purpose
positive things like doing art with her
and
planning planning things with her so
that when i am with her i'm fully
present
and i'm doing something that i intend
because in coaching i
constantly am looking at okay who do i
want to be as a mom
and what's our next breakthrough as
parents and justin i work on we both
have coaches and we work on this stuff
together
my parents didn't have coaches they were
talking about this
i know and i think about how my parents
could have benefited from just
one therapy session what just
a lifetime of changes yeah so we're both
like
multi-therapy we both do coaching
meditation all kinds of energy healing
work i've talked to mediums and
spiritual healers like i'm i'm
constantly working on this but i'm not
i'm not doing it in spite of my kid i'm
doing it
for and with and eventually with you
know yeah yeah yeah
for sure uh well i guess in that same
vein someone asked what's your favorite
part about being a mom and or do you
have any hilarious amelia stories
i mean i have way too many hilarious
amelia stories i'll tell you one
reason um so so i scratch her back
before
she we co-sleep with her so she sleeps
we're super crunchy like yes home birth
go sleep whatever um so she sleeps next
to me um and
and i scratch her back before her sleep
and she's like okay and back
and recently she goes and butt
and i was like you want me to scratch
your butt she goes okay
i'm like all right it's a little weird
but so i i scratched
i started scratching just at the top
right over under she says no underwear
i'm like okay well it's i just gave you
a bath but it's a little weird
amelia you're making this weird yeah i
just like moved her underwear down like
scratching
and like justin won't even do it so the
next day after this um
we're playing tiger where i'm a tiger
i'm chasing her
and um and she's she hides in the corner
and uh
and i i was getting tired so i didn't
want to anymore so i started scratching
her back while she was in the corner
and uh and she goes and butt and i'm
like
jesus i
yeah it's a thing now so i did it over
her clothes and she goes oh good job
tiger
oh i don't know how to feel about that
one
and that's also why motherhood scares
the [ __ ] out of me is that
i i can't that i'll just be like no
you're nasty justin says no justin won't
do it he's like okay
i think mommy will do that for you i'm
not doing that like whenever you came
out of my body
oh yeah that's true you have the you
have the free pass because you guys have
a closer connection obviously
um michelle this has already gone so
fast that we have to wrap up soon
but i know i for i want to know what's
next what are you working on and so many
people also want to know with that
uh you've been working on music and lin
manuel
recently responded to a piece of music
that you put up
uh how well um yeah i
i do a lot of stuff
really quick off the cuff like let me
just like throw together this thing
and that video was something that i i
said wow i've always loved this song
satisfied from hamilton i would love
to do it justice yes i spent over three
months working on that off and on like
when i had time i would rehearse i would
like practice it
which is not something i did i was like
one and done quick videos
yeah but i knew and i said it to my
coach i was like i really think that if
i
put the amount of effort into this that
the hamilton cats will see it because
if it's that good people will share it
and it will just get to them and then
they'll say something to me because
they'll have to because
they'll like it and they'll be like oh
this is such a
this i really wanna i like making the
stuff that's um
that's honoring the person who made the
original yeah like a gift to them like
it's almost like saying thank you for
making this because it's so inspiring
totally so i was like i was like healthy
i wasn't worried about it and if he
didn't i would be like okay maybe try
again
um but when i saw that he responded that
he watched it and he gave like the
nicest compliment it was just the
sweetest thing in the world what he said
i was like oh yeah
right so that's what i said
and it happened okay crazy what do i
want to say next
and my coach asked me that and i was
like how about i double my income in the
next year and she's like okay what else
i'll put out an album and like i'm not
i'm not just like bullshitting like i'm
very present right now to my ability to
what we call declare and fulfill like
say this is gonna happen and then do
whatever it takes to make it happen
versus vaguely describing what i would
like for it to happen in my life and
trying to manage
things to happen that way it's it's a
very different energy
yeah also because if you're not
dedicated and it doesn't work out then
technically you didn't fail
because you didn't put your all into it
exactly which is so my mo like that's so
what i would do wait until the morning
of to write the paper and then be like
oh well i didn't try that hard so
so trying is is the thing i'm in right
now and it's
really uncomfortable and i have to have
support structures like accountability
structures and like imacs that i'm not
going to get to open or else i won't do
it
yeah no that's great to recognize
um okay before we officially officially
wrap up
usually everyone that has given us
uh an hour of their time to speak on the
podcast when we do this in person
we give them a physical fortune cookie
that's personalized from us
to them but we're doing it virtually so
we have a digital fortune cookie that i
believe you've been given
what does this read this out that yes
please it says
you can't spell colorado without a cool
rod
make of that what you will yeah uh
that's a real personal one because
michelle told me she's thinking about
moving to colorado next year
and so i'm manifesting that for you
thank you grace this is a great fortune
this is the best fortune cookie i've
ever gotten because usually they're a
little off the rails
very true this one's very personalized
um michelle thanks for chatting with
us today this was really fun but where
can people that don't know where to find
you and everything that you're up to
where can they find you uh instagram
michelleakin21
that's me also michelleking.com it's my
website
uh and i'm on twitter michelle aiken
sweet
and you're always reposting uh
retweeting and posting on your story
like very inspirational stuff
um i'm inspirational on instagram and
i'm ridiculous on twitter so like
very true sometimes they cross over but
mostly twitter is like my dumping ground
for
nonsense and uh instagram is for
inspiring things
love it a little bit of everything so
guys go check her out if you're
interested in coaching
definitely go check her out and get
ready for new original music coming down
the pipes
yeah yeah very exciting thank you
michelle
and thank you everyone for listening and
watching we'll see you next time on
another episode of not too deep
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis
post-production sound by chris henry and
an extra special thanks to flula for the
theme music